une question mais mais comment ils vont
à eux bonjour je petit marais je parle
de hawaii à moustache
ouais je sais ça fait un peu bizarre au
début mais quand on s'y habitue on se
rend compte que ça me va assez bien faut
parfois dans la vie tu tombes sur le
truc cool avec lequel faut absolument
que tu te prennent en photo la lumière
est parfaite ce jour là tu as mis tes
meilleurs savent très bien quoi fêter au
max toutes les conditions sont réunies
pour faire la photo un stade parfaite
à un détail près mon pote qui prend la
photo c'est pas faire les photos comme
enlève le floch
alors soit il en a rien à [ __ ]
évidemment que je crierai vendredi chez
nikos à 250 personnes soit il sait pas
cadré alors qu'est ce qu'on pense alors
elle est pas mal
il manque juste mon visage quoi soit
sans faire exprès il fait ce truc hyper
énervant avec son doigt
ah tiens c'est marrant ya ton doigt qui
gâche la photo soit il met cinq ans à
faire la photo et toi tu vis un moment
bien gênant voilà au nickel nouveau j'ai
pas mon carré ça sera mieux comme sa
chose c'est bien
[Musique]
je mets le feu ça y est la [ __ ] je
suis en mode selphy comment tu retournes
la caméra haute opinion ou pas mal aux
bras ou alors tout simplement il a juste
aucun talent la photo que tu imaginé et
la photo que tu obtiens vraiment ce qui
fout la rage c'est que toi tu traînes
avec ce pote je te fais des photos nul
en permanence alors que toi tu lui fais
des purs photos qui méritent pas du tout
moi j'ai des vrais problèmes dans la vie
ok bon après des fois c'est toi qui
prends la photo mais c'est le modèle qui
est chiant à ça ça arrive assez souvent
en vertical s'appelait verticale et non
horizontale selarl a déjà fait un jeu la
revue quand même et c'est de bien va
voir hélas beaucoup et on va pas se
mentir alors appelés no-shows rires je
crois que le musée en train de fermer la
vue que j'ai un peu petit tu peux
baisser un peu stoppé juste une dernière
au caire juste une dingue juge plus
l'ambiance oui le pire c'est que ce mec
qui t'a demandé de prendre 1000 photos
absolument identique
tous demandent de choisir laquelle tu
préfères non mais attends mais
j'hallucine
à ce moment là dans ta tête tu joues au
jeu des 7 différences la main évidemment
la question c'est de savoir c'est
laquelle tu préfères entre les deux à ça
ça je sais pas quand on prend une photo
à 2 il ya toujours une petite bataille
parce qu'on se trouve pas forcément beau
sur les mêmes thèmes et dans ces
moments-là il ya toujours de la mauvaise
foi c'est inévitable et mon gars on est
tous les deux beaux gosses
ouais ouais tous les deux sauf moi mais
mes nettoie les deux beaux gosses
des fois quand je vois le compte un
stade une influence us je me dis [ __ ]
ya vraiment une vie de rêve ses photos
un style tu les superbes elles sont mais
qui doit voir trop de la chance quoi
[Applaudissements]
réalité mais rapproche toi moi c'est moi
faut qu'on voie le smoothie rapprocher
ce sondage que je te dise voilà on peut
c'est dégueulasse notamment quand tu
veux faire une photo de groupe
la personne qui est désigné pour prendre
la photo c'est toujours celui ou celle
qui est un peu moins pote avec les
autres c'est et si on prenait une belle
photo ensemble à grave grave qui va
prendre la photo choisie dans votre
boîte pourquoi moi à tanger pas dessus
bah tu les prends bien un petit et grand
ouais j'sais pas t'es pas trop nous
attend plus on t'aime pas bon ça va
alors allé serrer vous soyez très amis
très très amis voilà vous pensez à apam
l'envoyer au j'aime pas les gens sur
l'instinct qui met une photo en ligne et
qui font carrément à teaser de cette
photo dans leur story le genre c'est
vraiment l'événement du mois pour eux
quoi aller voir et lykke li na toutes
dernières photos sur un star elle est
clairement culte waouh c'est parti 3 2 1
je mange un yaourt
ceci n'est pas intéressant parfois tu
crois être en intimité avec une personne
sur snap tu envoies des petites poteaux
et des petits messages bien perso et
elle te réponds yes no aussi en fait un
gros bisou gé nial bon tout le monde
connaît la fameuse technique de se
rajouter un petit emoji sur le visage
pour cacher un bouton ou un petit défaut
après si la personne à qui tu parles tu
en vois ça
là faut se poser des questions peut-être
que il a le syndrome de d'avoir des
boutons
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo pensez à
cliquer sur la cloche sur ma chaîne
youtube pour recevoir toutes mes motifs
directement bam dans votre salon ou dans
votre
lieu de visionnage et sinon mettez un
petit femmes le top si vous avez
apprécié et puis sinon c'est tout ciao
petite marie jo d'athènes 13 une tuile
de toi c'est bien pas non c'est pas où
après je peux faire comme sa petite
marie tatin transit oye oye petit matin
la pression je peux faire ça aussi c'est
un morceau j'ai inventé
[Musique]